The joe rogan experience.
There's a movie I saw the other day,
uh,
about these two prostitutes from Amsterdam and there the roads,
they were like the oldest prostitutes ever.
Oh.
And they said that they saw more than 355,000 clients to date.
And they're,
they're twin sisters.
And there's,
uh,
oh my God.
Are you kidding me?
Yeah,
they just retired the other day,
but there's eight.
Just retired.
Yeah,
there's a,
there's a Netflix,
a movie all about them.
Uh,
documentary,
uh,
he's a Scooby Doo van for sale on Craig's list.
Oh,
there's a lot of those because of the law.
When the movies came out,
this could be doing one,
two,
and three.
They had a bunch of these like advertising vans.
So these ladies,
these ladies.
But anyways,
it was a really interesting,
uh,
documentary.
I can't think of the sea,
see if they say what it is,
but they're,
their name is Louise and Martine focons in their sisters that had been
prostitutes for over 50 years.
And,
uh,
it was the most creepiest documentary because they talked about how they didn't
really want to do it anymore.
They were kind of,
you know,
like,
I'm an old lady,
I don't want to do this.
But then they had to because they had no other choice because they had no money.
And uh,
you said I was a little tired.
That's her quote.
I,
those are the [inaudible] I was a little tired,
tired.
Luis told as it happens,
host Carol off in an interview that aired March 18th.
The sister said that old age and arthritis where the main reasons for their
retirement,
and I've written about their exploits in the new book called the ladies of
Amsterdam.
That's how they would walk down the street.
And the documentary was kind of cute.
Does cause there was so such an old ladies,
you know?
Oh my God.
But it was awesome.
Really disturbing.
They look like dude's pretending to be old ladies.
Like one of those theme movies like Benny Pills.
Yeah,
they'd look Dustin Hoffman.
Yes.
Yeah,
they do.
they look fake.
Yeah.
Look to Benny Hills and dresses.
Their body just becomes like a battleground and all the Siv,
HIV,
STD,
syphilis,
gonorrhea,
aids,
it all just battles it out together for dominance,
see who wins.
And meanwhile she stays healthy.
She's tastes healthy cause they didn't attack each other.
They don't even go after the immune system.
I mean as if though your kids,
that's when it would really gross you out.
Imagine if you had a kid with a chick and then you weren't really that into it
and you kinda like kept away from her and laughed and didn't pay child support
and she went into property and then he found out many years later that your kid
retired as the oldest prostitute ever in Amsterdam.
You know,
man,
you want to talk about regret at someone's a little girl.
That's someone's,
a little girl.
That was someone's little cute baby that was so sweet and everything she said
was adorable.
Oh my goodness.
Look at her.
She's so precious.
Next thing you know,
it doesn't really end that well.
This story.
Well,
how did it end?
do you really want to hear the end?
Yeah.
Well they became a prostitute for 50 years and soc 350,000 decks.
It was safe before.
No.
Yeah.
It's interesting when a culture like drastically changes over a fairly short
period of time.
I used to go to Mexico and we just go to the spring break thing.
MTV in like the late nineties you know,
maybe like to name names late,
maybe even the early two thousands it was like no big deal.
Yeah.
Why was it was it was for fear factor.
The grind.
Yeah.
Me,
you and Eric were on the ground together.
We used to get our pump on,
taught me how to shave my chest.
I believe all of this totally right.
Yeah.
Were dance partners.
We're,
we're,
we're going to be the first gay couple on dances with the stars.
We're going to come on and go.
He's going to help me.
You guys fuck each other honest with you.
For how long?
Like an hour or I could watch that longer than the head cutting.
What'd you get?
You Watch two guys?
Fuck.
Easier than it had ever seen.
Two guys.
Fuck you.
Still time.
I find that hard to believe why?
You mean in real life or on the Internet?
I've never even watched it on the Internet.
Well,
pull it up for it,
Brian.
All right.
Yeah.
Okay.
Well,
so Brian,
the only way this is gonna work is take the monitor and um,
don't upstream downstream the show and then on that screen over there you need
to show two guys.
Fuck.
And just for Amy.
So,
well it won't ever show.
You can do that,
right?
I think the guys,
I want it to be earthquake fire.
Going to find out mixmaster flesh.
Go it.
Best master flesh.
I actually invented that name.
Makes us your guy's name is flash mixed master flash.
Like that guy's a master flesh.
[inaudible] Jang Triangle booking by accident.
Yeah.
Right.
It just fucks.
Everybody just shows up and flings deck.
My name is cheese cream.
Yeah.
Oh,
it you the new porn.
I mean,
can I get a rap name?
Yeah,
well my rap name be,
I always felt like if we're going to have a nickname,
you can't really nickname yourself like that.
That's annoying is you can always tell when someone tried to push their own
nickname.
Do I say introduce you as their nickname?
She was fuck to call me shrooms and my volleyball team.
It didn't really catch on shrooms.
Shrooms.
I know that you've done,
you've made your own nickname up.
It means you have no friends.
That's the only thing it means.
Yeah,
it doesn't make any sense.
Other than that they were crazy person.
Crazy person.
Hey guys,
I'm going to be t rex.
You know,
cause I'm always talking like this.
Yeah,
the fighters,
it's hilarious.
Fighters come up with some of the silliest nicknames.
Power,
they have to stick with it
and it's there forever.
Well No,
some guys change like a Rory Macdonald.
He used to call himself the waterboy.
Yeah.
And then he changed his to Aries.
Aries God of war,
right?
Yeah.
It's kind of interesting where you're allowed to change your name,
change
being the waterboy,
but now I feel more like the god of war.
Oh,
okay.
Just do whatever you want.
Ah,
I million people is that people fucking [inaudible] it's,
you know what?
They fucking right there because he just,
he pulled up to elderly fat guys fucking,
and I'm not like,
no.
You know what,
I maybe you're right.
Maybe I assumed it was going to be like,
take it away.
Right.
That's not cool.
We're not going to get an honest reaction.
As long as she's seen it.
Now we can say that we were the first person to show it.
She goes,
oh,
she's looking right at it right now.
You know what?
It doesn't bother me.
She's looking right at it.
You just got it.
Okay.
I honestly don't feel bummed out about it.
We're good.
We'll get to the sex.
No,
no,
no.
That's enough.
It's not bothering me.
It's honestly not bothered.
[inaudible] they're blowing each other like two gentlemen who might erode their
mouth.
Fucking I call him.
I'll fucking,
yeah.
I don't know.
I,
you know what?
I didn't see them penetrating each other.
That might've been a different vibe.
I didn't mind that 69.
Yeah.
We need to get,
you know,
you got to prove that you see the actual fucking,
I seen him right there,
clearly.
Yeah.
I,
uh,
I thought it was going to bum me out,
but yeah,
fuck him.
Okay.
There you go.
That's great.
Well,
thank you guys.
We got to do this together.
You're welcome.
So anyway,
[inaudible]
you ready to,
of course recording.
Oh,
it is already.
What the fuck's on?